if you have been around the strip this
week you've probably noticed more group
events more conventions
thanks for joining us at 6 30 i'm denise
valdis and i'm brian loft it's just a
week ago the first convention since the
beginning of the pandemic world of
concrete started victoria saha reporting
another popular attraction back now too
conventions and events are making a
comeback here in las vegas
the bear jackson car auction is expected
to bring in 65
thousand people this weekend people from
all across the country are coming here
to bid on luxurious cars
the auction is taking place at the new
west hall
after having to postpone the auction due
to the pandemic
barrett-jackson ceo craig jackson is
glad to revive this event
and visitors are happy to attend we
really feel like we're part of
the fabric of las vegas we're not
just out of towners coming in here we're
part of this community
everybody can come down here and enjoy
barrett jackson without any of the
restrictions
and i feel like the excitement is here
i had to stay at home and by
social distance all that stuff it's nice
being here
seeing the crowd this auction with
attendees from all over the nation
provides a 40
million dollar boost to our economy the
auction goes until saturday and it's
open to the public you can buy your
tickets
through the barrett-jackson website
reporting from the west hall at the
convention center victoria saha 8 news
now
and 25 000 people expected to attend the
auction
on saturday denise